and what about jenny cheerleader
can you just forget about her oh jenny
well you know jenny's special
even if i never see her again she's
still special
let's do uh
andrea
what did yoda say
there's no try there is do and not do
and anybody that doesn't cold read aloud
30 minutes every day gets doo-doo
that's how i read novels because i can
never read anything right
i started reading 1984 it's actually
really good i'm cold reading that now
george orwell like why haven't i read
that before yeah it's a great book
really kids are really good
remember guys readers aren't leaders but
leaders are readers
terry truman
you want to be a leader in any field you
got to be a reader i mean it's so good
that the 30 minutes of like the things
my bell rings and i'm like really what i
like
good good you time your reading that's
good
how are we in the booth good start
oh i start yeah of course
we're rolling
we have speed
you know what i admire most about you
i don't know is it my brilliant mind
or my gorgeous insatiable body
the way you're so goddamn cheerful the
way you did the cartwheels today
fantastic
nothing to it
see the air was champagne and it made me
drunk
it's not that easy chrissy
people are different you're just so open
to people everyone i'm not that way i've
got walls built around me
why why not just trade them down
well i mean it's not that easy
like a lot of [ __ ] up things happened
to me when i was a kid a lot of [ __ ]
up things happen to a lot of people when
they were kids
maybe so but i've learned to tune things
out
not let people too close
i mean work is great i'm work i'm great
at work but
people hurt you and what you don't feel
can't hurt you
okay see that's what's wrong philly
it's not feeling what hurts you
you've got to learn to open up
you've got to learn to love people
you've got to
love
stupid people
bad ladies whiners
dirty old man
and i know how it may sound but they're
people you know uh they're live
it's and it that's the greatest thing in
the universe
it's so
beautiful and sacred
and it's free
it's all around us
just dig it wallow in it
wow
you're so damn great chrissy
okay see
i don't understand you
i really don't
i don't understand this thing with you
and your grandfather
well why can't you just forget the old
fart already
it's like a family curse
or something
jeez
it's hard to explain my grandfather my
grandfather is texas
i mean he thinks he could buy anything
he wants
he tried to buy me once
and what he can't buy he wants to
destroy does that make sense to you
not
really he destroyed my father no wait he
crippled him
you shouldn't ignore wade
you either love him or hate him
and what about jenny cheerleader why
can't you just forget about her
oh
jenny well
jenny's special
even even if i never saw her again she'd
still be special
oh my god look she dumped all over you
okay just quit moaning about her
i'm sorry chrissy
you're wonderful
come on today
maybe some
good healthy sex we'll bring it back to
your memories so oh wow
very cut
there we go lovely good for you you're
you're you know your your english do you
do you realize how
much better your english is now
than it was six months ago yeah
man there's just a huge difference and
just by doing it cold drinking a lot
every day you do have the exercise that
i gave everybody right you're doing that
you have a lovely gal from
brazil
portuguese who's
working on that exercise with me
and doing a fabulous job and vasily of
course has worked on it for months since
he's been here and it just shows so
you're working real hard at it good for
you
that's a lovely work
lovely work bed you okay it's a lot of
crap
i was like that there's no cussing in
this why did i say that
well i don't care because i haven't said
the f word tonight you thought you'd
fill in for me
yeah we have an f quarter tonight so uh
we're we're meeting it blank you be
quiet uh
you don't have words for you although
you did see it one night which was quite
a
wonderful
uh it warmed the cuckles of my heart
he's a big boy he's in middle school
yeah
he's heard that word before yes
[Laughter]
dad stop talking like that around the
kids
okay good all right let's do it again um
no i i like what you did just change it
up just give me a different read
you know okay
i just go no no
you'll get your words from the booth
all right you start veggie
we are rolling
take your own action
you know what i admire the most about
you
my brilliant minds
or my gorgeous insatiable body
the way you're so goddamn cheerful all
the time
the way you did those cartwheels earlier
on fantastic
nothing to it you know
the year was champagne it made me drunk
it's not that easy people are different
you're so open to people to everyone i'm
not that way
i've got walls around me
why though
why not just tear them down
it's not that easy a lot of crap
happened to me when i was a kid
a lot of crap happened to everyone when
they were a
maybe so but i've learned to tune things
out not to let anybody too close
and work is great i mean i'm great at
work
but people hurt you
you
can't be hurt by things you don't feel
that's wrong philip
that's not how it works
you
you've got to open up
you've got to learn how to love people
you've you've got to love all those
rhinos and stupid people
and
bad ladies and dirty old man
because they're people
in their life
and that's the greatest thing in the
universe
it's beautiful and it's sacred
and it's free
it's all around us
digging it
wallow in it
wow
you're so damn great chrissy
i don't understand
i i really don't
this thing with you and your grandfather
why can't you just forget the old fart
already
it's like a family curse or something
i can't explain my grandfather my
grandfather is texas
i mean he thinks he could buy anything
he wants he tried to buy me once and
what he doesn't buy he wants to destroy
does that make sense to you
i don't think so
he destroyed my dad no wait
crippled him
but you can't ignore wade you either
love him or hate
and what about jenny cheerleader
can you just forget about her oh jenny
well you know jenny's special
even if i never see her again she's
still special oh look she dumped all
over you just quit moaning about her
you need to understand
that there was a point in my life when
my mother and jenny were the only people
i cared about
okay to hell jenny what about me
oh
i'm sorry chrissy you're wonderful
come to bedford maybe some good healthy
sex will help you bringing you back to
your senses
and cut there we go nice
you just shut the hell out of philip
i was ready to run upstairs but
uh
good that's good good good good good
lovely good work okay uh kenny and max